the question is this is your sixth
studio album how would you say justice
differs from the others and who are some
artists you
want to collaborate with in the future
sorry my wife is just walking in
hi hi haley i'm on i'm
interview call sorry all right she's
she's sitting there she's chilling
okay um i'm gonna just show her because
hi hayley
hi helmut okay so this is your sixth
studio album how would you say justice
differs from the others
and who do you like plan on
collaborating with next in the future
so i would say that um wow this this
album differs from the others i just
think
um i continue to evolve and i continue
to change and i continue to grow and i
continue to
uh just find new reasons and meanings
and
um and i think that that's obviously the
goal for every project is just to
continue to
you know i i've i've kind of obviously
it's like
there's there's pressure to outdo each
project but
i think as long as i just look at it
through the eyes of like
wow like i have another opportunity to
um
you know use what god's put inside me to
to make
other people happy that's been that's
been the driving motivation
motivator for me and so um that's been
really helpful
um and then the next question you asked
i think was regarding
um uh the next collaborator yeah um
i really um man i really love
uh scizza justin doan oh my god are you
serious
yes i love her oh my god i'm ready i'm
ready for it
wow i love her yeah
and do you know her the artist yeah okay
i didn't i didn't know if you you
thought i met her
as far as
which who i i think is super super
talented so
that's why i like you you have a
phenomenal taste in music you have a
good sound
thank you of course
[Music]